écouter il est 20h et 43 minutes et pour
refermer ce journal spécial et avant de
passer la main à envoyer spécial pour
d'autres reportages et bien nous avons
voulu revenir sur cette semaine que le
Japon n'oubliera jamais cette semaine ou
la troisième puissance mondiale a vu
deux vagues l'affaire vaciller celle du
tsunami puis celle de la peur la peur
des radiations voici ce récit un film
heure par heure avec des imaginésites un
récit signé Olivier Caroff
c'est visible à l'oeil nu les immeubles
tangent
et voici l'intérieur
deux minutes sans interruption
c'était le début de l'après midi les
Japonais travaillaient faisaient leurs
courses ou promener les enfants
la secousse a été ressenti sur des
centaines de kilomètres elle a déplacé
le pays de 2 mètres une manitude
exceptionnelle trois précédents
seulement en un siècle
cet habitant du nord-ouest de Tokyo à
tout filmé chez lui
il était à l'étage quand la terre s'est
mise à trembler
les enfants ont trouvé abri sous les
tables des gestes à prier répéter tant
de fois au cas où
la maison encaisse les vibrations tout
le monde va bien c'est le soulagement
mais nous sommes à 260 km de l'épicentre
et bien plus au nord le séisme a libéré
une monstrueuse énergie en pleine mer
alerte tsunami 6 mètres de haut
pronostic la météo
ce qui s'abat sur les côtes nord-est
dépassent l'imagination
Minami Sanriku le monde entier va
apprendre le nom de ces villes
martyrisés
des villes où une moitié de la
population à littéralement disparu
nous sommes moins d'une heure après de
séance
il fallait sans doute de la chance ce
jour-là pour survivre à cet endroit-là
avoir eu le temps de gagner les hauteurs
être dans le bon bâtiment
celui que la marée debout a choisi
d'épargner
les dégâts sont considérables
décident industriels sont touchés eux
aussi c'est là encore le tsunami qui a
provoqué l'essentiel des destructions
très spectaculaire comme cette
raffinerie mais cinq heures après le
séisme c'est dans un lieu apparemment
intact que commence à se jouer le
troisième acte de la tragédie
la centrale nucléaire de Fukushima
alerte de précaution dans l'un des six
réacteurs le système de refroidissement
est en panne
nord-est du Japon le jour d'après
et montagne de débris comme laissé au
hasard quel que soit leur taille de
simples jouets pour le tsunami
les morts pour la plupart sont encore
invisibles emportés
à s'organiser réfugiés sur les toiles et
rescapés résume tant trois lettres ce
que le pays tout entier va ressentir
car en fin d'après-midi à Fukushima
cette image muette de vidéourveillance
c'est bien une explosion dans la
centrale nucléaire mais ce n'est pas une
explosion nucléaire pour les autorités
la nuance et de taille
nous confirmons l'explosion à Fukushima
du bâtiment numéro 1 et une légère fuite
radioactive mais l'enceinte du réacteur
n'a pas été touché
dans la nuit plus de 100000 personnes
vont être évacuées l'accident est classé
4 sur une échelle de gravité de 7 et 7
c'est tchernoby
tenue anti-contamination zone de
sécurité
pastillodes césium radiation le
vocabulaire d'une crise nucléaire
dans la matinée l'hypothèse pessimiste
devient un nom officiel situation
d'urgence
la panne dans la centrale dure depuis 48
heures et elle va encore s'aggraver
deuxième explosion c'est le bâtiment du
réacteur numéro 3 le réacteur numéro 2
lui commence à entrer en fusion
le monde entier scrute désormais chaque
image d'un danger si peu visible tandis
qu'au nord du pays
on ne sait plus quoi
où regarder
Miami San Ricou comptait 17000 âmes les
plages étaient réputées pour leur beauté
à l'hôpital l'un des rares bâtiments à
avoir tenu l'eau et montée jusqu'au 2e
étage celui du service pédiatrique
il y a des secoursistes mais reste-t-il
quelqu'un à ce courrier
on fouille partout on a encore de
l'espoir des Fukushima pendant ce
temps-là n'en finit pas de distiller ces
mauvaises nouvelles
troisième explosion en trois jours
il y a maintenant 4 réacteurs différents
en surchauffe crise nucléaire de niveau
6 un seul cran en dessous de Tchernobyl
le lendemain l'empereur prend la parole
c'est exceptionnel il va prier dit-il
car la situation est désormais
imprévisible
qu'avait-on prévu un séisme oui un
tsunami aussi mais ni l'une ni l'autre
de ces calamités naturelles n'a
directement touché
Kushi le cauchemar nucléaire vécu en
direct par toute la planète est né d'une
panne électrique près de la centrale une
simple panne électrique